N
HIM?
>> Brian: HE IS ON AN ENERGY
REPORT.
>> Steve: I THOUGHT IT WAS THE
SAME.
>> Brian: IF YOU ARE A STUDENT
OF HISTORY REMEMBER BACK --
REMEMBER A TIME THERE WERE TENT
CITIES ACROSS AMERICA AND THEY
REFER TO THEM AS HOOVERVILLE?
I WONDER IF THIS TENT CITY THAT
THEY WILL BE BUILDING HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY, IF THEY WILL BE
REFERRING TO IT AS BIDEN VILLE
BEING HOUSED WITH MIGRANTS WHO
PULLS A THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY GIVEN WHAT
JOE BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION POLICY
IS AN ESSENTIALLY, YOU WANT TO
COME IN AND YOU COME IN.
SO REALLY DEDICATE THOSE TENTS
TO JOE BIDEN WHO IS MAKING THIS
POSSIBLE.
>> Ainsley: OUR MAYOR SAY THAT
SHELTERS ARE OVERWHELMED SO THEY
HAVE TO PUT UP THESE TENTS.
IT IS ESTIMATED 13,600 MIGRANTS
IN NEW YORK CITY.
AND HE SAYS THE BULK OF THOSE
MORE THAN 10,000 ARE IN CITY
SHELTERS.
THE FIRST EMERGENCY SHELTERS
CONSIST OF THE FIVE TENSE AS YOU
SAID, STEVE, TORTURED BEACH IN
THE BRONX AND HAVE ENOUGH BEDS
TO HOUSE 1,000 ADULTS AND
OFFICIALS WILL ASSESS THEIR
HEALTH AND WELFARE AND REPLACE
HIM IN THE SHELTER SYSTEM.
>> Brian: I JUST LAUGHED WHEN
THIS MAYOR SAYS I'M DOING THESE
REFUGEE STYLE CAMPS.
I'M ACTUALLY RESPONSIBLY UNLIKE
THOSE GOVERNORS IN FLORIDA OR
ARIZONA AND TEXAS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA HOW NAIVE
YOU SOUND?
YOU ARE TALKING WITH GOVERNORS
THAT FOR THE MOST PART IN
FLORIDA'S CASE GET REFUGEES
FLOWN IN WITHOUT GIVING A HEADS
UP.
YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT WHO'S NOT
TO NOT KNOWING WHO'S ON THESE
BUSES COMING YOUR WAY?
HOW DO YOU FEEL 4 MILLION PEOPLE
CROSSING THE BORDER AND DO YOU
THINK THEY CALL AHEAD OF TIME TO
SAY SAVE THIS DATE?
THIS IS WHEN I'M ARRIVING WITH
LITTLE POSTCARDS?
NO ONE KNOWS WHO'S ARRIVING
THERE.
YOU TALK ABOUT HAVING A HARD.
THEY ARE SO BIG AND SO
OVERWHELMED THAT THEY ARE
INFRINGING ON THE LIVES OF THE
PEOPLE OF THE BORDER CITIES.
HE CAN'T HANDLE -- I GUESS,
12,000 IN FOUR MONTHS?
10,000 BUSES?
THAT IS TWO DAYS.
THESE ARE SMALL TOWNS.
YOU GOT THE BIGGEST CITY IN THE
COUNTRY.
SAME WITH CHICAGO.
>> Steve: IT IS 8,000 PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER EVERY DAY.
THAT IS WHAT WE KNOW OF.
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY, THEY HAVE
2,000 LAST WEEK AND ABOUT 14,000
SO FAR.
AND SO OPENED UP A FACILITY...
BE ONE IN THE BRONX.
>> Steve: FORGET ABOUT THE
TENT CITY THEY HAVE OPENED UP
HOTELS IN NEW YORK CITY TO
HANDLE THE MIGRANTS.
HERE IS THE THING, YOU
KNOW, YOU'RE A SANCTUARY CITY IN
NEW YORK CITY.
ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATS, SO
HISTORICALLY IF YOU WANT TO COME
TO NEW YORK CITY, THEY WILL ASK
YOU ABOUT YOUR IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, DO YOU
REMEMBER SEEING ANYTHING LIKE
THIS A FLOW OF MIGRANTS INTO
NEW YORK, NEW YORK, WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Brian: IT WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
>> Steve: BECAUSE IT WAS HARD
TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY.
NOW IT IS EASY.
NOW IT IS A PROBLEM HERE THEY
SAY IT IS A SANCTUARY CITY EVEN
THOUGH THEY COME HERE, THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET RID OF THEM
ESSENTIALLY AND SHELTER THEM
SOMEPLACE.
>> Brian: THIS VIDEO, THIS IS
WHY THIS IS DETRIMENTAL.
IF YOU LISTEN TO JEH JOHNSON
HOMELAND SECURITY AND THE BORDER
COMMUNITY HENRY CUELLAR, HE SAYS
IF YOU WILL SEND PEPCO, THEY
SEND THEM BACK, THEY NEED TO SEE
THE VIDEO OF BEING SENT BACK AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY NEED TO SEE
WHAT REMAINED IN MEXICO LOOKS
LIKE.
SO THEY GO, "HONEY, THIS IS NOT
A GOOD TIME TO SENT THEM EXCEL
THE HOUSE AND GIVE THE MONEY TO
THE CARTELS AND CROSS THE RIVER
AS A RISK."
THEY NEVER SHOWED THE VIDEO BUT
INSTEAD WE GET THIS, BEAUTIFUL
NEW YORK CITY.
WHO WONDERFUL LOOKING MAN IN A
NICE SUIT AND WE SEE THE
FAMILIES AND THEY GET TO GET THE
WELCOME PACKAGES, iPHONES AND
THEY CARE ABOUT THE SIX HOTELS
AND THOUSANDS OF HOTEL ROOMS.
THIS IS THE TIME TO FLEE MY
COUNTRY.
>> Ainsley: YOU BROUGHT UP A
GOOD POINT, MINE I NEVER THOUGHT
ABOUT.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE LIBERAL
MAYORS COMPLAINING BECAUSE I
DIDN'T GET A WARNING.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT, APP IT NEVER
GOT A WARNING.
THESE MIGRANTS AREN'T CALLING
HIM AND SAYING I'M COMING OVER,
8,000 ARE COMING OVER THIS WEEK.
>> Steve: THIS MORNING
JOE BIDEN OPENED UP OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM THOUGH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T WATCH THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
IN A POSITION OF POWER ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
HAD YOU SEEN IT, YOU WOULD HAVE
SEEN VILMA LUCIAN SHOWING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE STREAMING I.
JUST DOING THE MAP AND
CONNECTING THE DOTS, WHERE THEY
CAN AGO, THEY ARE COMING HERE.
>> Ainsley: IN WASHINGTON
OPENING THE BORDER NOT EVEN FOR
AN HOUR, 20, 40 MINUTES AND SHE
FLEW TO CALIFORNIA BUT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NEVER BEEN DOWN
THERE AS PRESIDENT,
VICE PRESIDENT AND AS A SENATOR
AND SO THEY ARE SITTING IN
WASHINGTON COMPLAINING ABOUT
THIS AND BLAMING IT -- YOU SAID
YOU WE NEVER SAW THESE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT WE ARE
BLOOMING WHAT WAS SEEN ON TRUNK.
LISTEN.
>> THEY ARE PLAYING GAMES.
THESE ARE POLITICAL STRUCK DOWN
NEXT HUMAN BEINGS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
VENEZUELA RIGHT NOW?
HUMAN BEINGS, REAL PEOPLE WHO
HAVE FLED WHO CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA SEEKING
REFUGE, ASYLUM.
I THINK IT IS THE HEIGHT OF YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY MUCH LESS FRANKLY
A DERELICTION OF DUTY WHEN YOU
ARE AN ELECTED LEADER TO PLAY
THOSE KINDS OF GAMES WITH HUMAN
LIFE.
>> Ainsley: DERELICTION OF
DUTY...
>> Brian: CAN YOU BELIEVE SHE
USE THAT TERM WHEN IT'S HER
RESPONSIBILITY?
>> Ainsley: IF THEY ARE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, WHY DO THEY
CARE THEY ARE SHIPPING THEM TO
DIFFERENT STATES QUESTIONNAIRE
THAT ALLOWS HIM TO COMMENCE
SANCTUARY STATES.
>> Steve: I WONDER IF THE
PERSON WHO INTERVIEWED HER ON
FISA NEWS, YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF
THE ROOT CAUSES OF WHY PEOPLE
COME HERE.
HAVE YOU ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES
TO KEEP THEM FROM COMING BACK?
AND SHE WOULD SAY, YES, I'VE
ADDRESSED IT."
>> Ainsley: AT THE REPORTER
DID ASK DID ASK KAMALA HARRIS DO
YOU UNDERSTAND THE SITUATION AT
THE BORDER?
AND SHE BLAMED DONALD TRUMP,
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
>> Steve: HER JOB IS TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO STOP PEOPLE
FROM COMING HERE AND HAVING THEM
STAY THERE.
>> Brian: AT THE SAME TIME
SHE'S LOOKING AT REFORM, K.G. P
WAS ON THE VIEW YESTERDAY THE
PRESS SECRETARY AND SHE IS
FANNING OUT TO TAKE THIS
TERRIBLE ISSUE THAT
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS AND
GREG ABBOTT HAS PUT IN THE FRONT
PAGE AND WE CAN ESCAPE THIS,
THIS IS DEVASTATING AND HOW DO
WE SPEND IT, LET'S BLAME IT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
WE WANT TO DO REFORM AND ARE YOU
KIDDING, SHE SAYS THIS, OUR
ADMINISTRATION ATTEMPTED TO FIX
THE ADMINISTRATION BUT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT DECIMATED IT.
NOBODY -- HERE IS THE PROBLEM
YOU CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
YOU DIDN'T LIKE REMAIN IN
MEXICO, YOU DIDN'T WANT TO BUILD
THE WALL.
A BILLION DOLLARS TO REPURPOSE
MILITARY FUNDS.
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO PUT TARIFFS
ON MEXICO.
YOU SAID THAT'S NOT WHAT A GOOD
NEIGHBOR DOES.
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE THE AIDE
AWAY FROM FOR CENTRAL AMERICANS,
THESE TRIBAL STOMA COUNTRIES AND
YOU TRY TO STOP IT IN THE
SENATE.
BECAUSE JARED KUSHNER, JUST
REMEMBER RECENT HISTORY.
EVERYTHING HE DID YOU HATED, BUT
IT WORKED.
THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
IN 2017, 48,000 CROSSED MY
201,858,000 CROSSED, AND BY THE
TIME JOE BIDEN TAKES OVER,
146,000 BORDER CROSSINGS YEAR TO
DATE.
THAT IS JUST IN THE AREA OF THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
>> Steve: AND JOE --
SEAN HANNITY ASKED THE FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP ABOUT
THOSE PEOPLE STREAMING INTO THE
COUNTRY AND HAVE THIS ANSWER
FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
WATCH.
>> MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE IN OUR
COUNTRY NOW THAT SHOULDN'T BE
HERE.
MANY OF THEM ARE PRISONERS.
>> DID YOU DEPORT THEM?
CRIMINALS.
THE BAD ONES I WOULD DEPORT, THE
BAD ONES I WOULD DEPORT.
VENEZUELA IS ENTERING THE
PRESENT POPULATION OF GOING
THROUGH THE BORDER LIKE NOTHING.
WE ARE POLICING OUR COUNTRY AND
IT IS VERY HARD TO COME BACK
FROM THAT.
I WANT TO SEE GREAT LEADERSHIP
IN THIS COUNTRY.
MORE IMPORTANT THAN REPUBLICAN,
DEMOCRAT OR CONSERVATIVE, WHAT I
WANT TO SEE GREAT LEADERSHIP.
OUR COUNTRY IS GOING TO.
DONATION IS IN DECLINE.
>> Brian: HE SAID YESTERDAY I
WANT TO SEE JOE BIDEN DO A
GOOD JOB.
I WANT TO SEE HIM DO A GOOD JOB.
IS HE?
YOU MAKE THE CALL.
WE WILL FIND OUT WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK IN SIX
WEEKS.
>> Steve: WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
HOW WE ARE IMPACTING IN
NEW YORK CITY BUT CAN YOU
IMAGINE LIVING ON THE
BORDER?
WE WILL SHOW YOU A SOUND BITE OF
A GUY WHO TOOK A CAMERA IN HIS
BACKYARD BECAUSE EIGHT MIGRANTS
BROKEN INTO GRANDPA'S HOUSE.
IT HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
IN THIS VIDEO, YOU WILL ACTUALLY
SEE HE SO CLOSE TO THE BORDER
YOU CAN SEE THE BORDER WALL IN
ITS RIGHT IN HIS BACKYARD.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS MY HOUSE, OKAY
QUESTION WORKED THE HOUSE WHERE
I LIVE WITH MY CHILDREN IN THIS
HOUSE RIGHT HERE, OKAY?
THERE'S THE [BLEEP] WALL.
[BLEEP], THE SECURITY CAMERA
FOOTAGE.
EIGHT INDIVIDUALS JUST [BLEEP]
[BLEEP] THE WALL RUNNING, OKAY,
RUNNING!
RAN RIGHT THROUGH HERE, RAN
RIGHT THROUGH HERE AND TRY TO GO
IN MY DOOR BUT MY FRONT DOOR WAS
LOCKED.
WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY WERE INSIDE MY GRANDPA'S
HOUSE.
A K, FOUR OF THEM BARRICADED
THEMSELVES INSIDE MY 90-YEAR-OLD
GRANDPA'S HOUSE, OKAY?
ALL MALES, ALL CARING.
>> Brian: ALL MALES AND ALL
CARING HIS 95-YEAR-OLD GRANDPA'S
HOUSE.
>> Ainsley: HOW GREAT WOULD
THAT LEAD TO LIVE ON THE
PROPERTY WITH THEIR GRANDPARENTS
IN THE WHOLE FAMILY.
THE KIDS BEING RAISED TOGETHER
THE COUSINS AND THEN THIS
HAPPENS.
THEY WORK SO HARD FOR AND HOW
THESE MIGRANTS WHO ARE ARMED, IT
SOUNDED LIKE HE SAID, BREAKING
IN HIS GRANDFATHER'S HOUSE
TRYING TO GET INTO HIS HOUSE
WITH KIDS.
>> Steve: THIS IS THE CONTENT
YOU WILL SEE FOX NEWS DIGITAL
COME UP FOXNews.com.
MEANWHILE NEW YORK CITY OF THE
PORTER AUTHORITY OF NEW YORK AND
NEW JERSEY, IS THE SECOND BUS
LOADED WITH PASSENGERS FROM
TEXAS ARRIVING HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
I CAN SEE THE PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE THE MASTS ON AND THEY
WILL BE COMING OUT IN JUST A
MINUTE.
ACTUALLY, I THINK THAT COULD BE
THE THIRD ONES COME I THINK WE
HAD AN EARLIER ONE, AND SEMI IN
FRONT OF THAT.
MORE PEOPLE TO BE WELCOME TO
NEW YORK CITY AND SOON, SOME OF
THEM MAY BE STAYING IN A BIG
TENT IN THE PARKING LOT.
>> Brian: I USED TO SEE
REFUGEES LOOKING DESPERATE.
I DON'T SEE A LOT OF DESPERATE
PEOPLE AND A LOT OF THEM HAVE
CLOTHING DEALS.
THEY ARE COMING YEAR BECAUSE IT
IS A BETTER COUNTRY THAN THE ONE
THEY LEFT.
THAT IS NOT THE WAY IT WORKS!
THERE IS A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET GREEN CARDS AND
WORK VISAS THE RIGHT WAY, AND
THE PRISON IS ALLOWING THEM TO
BUST OUR SYSTEM.
MAKE A MOCKERY OF IT.
AND I BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
WON'T PUT HIS HANDS ON THE
WHEEL, WE HAVE STATES AND CITIES
FIGHTING AGAINST EACH OTHER IN
THIS COUNTRY.
FOR A CITY THAT JUST WAS TOLD
TAKE 3% OUT OF EVERY DIVISION
BECAUSE OF BUDGET CUTS, WE ARE
NOW GIVING -- WE GAVE A
$34 MILLION CONTRACT TO THE
BRONX FAMILY NETWORK TO BUILD
TEN CITIES IN THE BRONX.
VERY CLOSE TO THE ZOO, I WOULD
IMAGINE INTO FLORIDA.
SO THEY CAN GO TO COLLEGE AND
HAVE RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
>> Steve: IF I HAD TO GUESS, I
WOULD SAY THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING
THE MIGRANTS OFF YET BECAUSE THE
WELCOMING COMMITTEE THE CITY OF
NEW YORK IS NOT